sous le coude et on vient ramener le
bras dans l'espace
cela pourrait ressembler à une séance de
sport classique
pourtant ici dans cet espace alloué par
la ville de nice
on tente de se remettre de ce que l'on
appelle le gobie de long une véritable
souffrance pour les personnes qui en
sont victimes
avait elle est complètement changé je
suis quelqu'un de très actif déjà je
travaillais j'avais beaucoup d'activités
de sports et maintenant ils rien n'est
possible
je suis très vite essoufflé je suis vite
fatigué et j'ai pu vraiment je suis plus
la même personne
ça m'a surtout perturbé
psychologiquement j'ai fait des crises
d'angoissé 2 3 fois et actuellement ça
m'a laissé un petit peu perturbée au
niveau de l'anxiété
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
estime que 10% des patients qu'ovide
souffrent encore de symptômes
trois mois après la maladie si on
explique encore mal ce phénomène des
solutions commencent à se mettre en
place
c'est le cas du dispositif miss acquis
santé lancé il y a deux semaines par la
municipalité azuréenne un programme qui
se décline sur 12 semaines et qui
prévoit notamment des séances de remise
en forme est sûre une première séance
sur les copies de long sur les personnes
qui ont des séquelles longue on a
travaillé en fonction des tests
physiques on a passé la semaine dernière
et aujourd'hui on sait on s'est
concentré sur lui renforcement
musculaire général au niveau du corps et
des exercices de cardio pour récupérer
en terme d'ambiance
autre point abordé par le programme la
dimension diététique et psychologique
alors diététique parce qu'on se rend
compte que beaucoup de personnes ont
perdu l'odorat et le goût et cette perte
la entraîne un déséquilibre dans la
façon de s'alimenter
par exemple une personne ne va plus
sentir le sel donc va sera salée à
outrance et cette personne a
potentiellement de l'hypertension enfin
voila il va y avoir un déséquilibre qui
va falloir va fort trouver une solution
en tout cas pour que cette personne
retrouve le goût et l'odorat pour
pouvoir s'alimenter correctement et au
niveau du suivi psychologique
on se rend compte que les personnes
vivent ce qu'on appelle un
sic au traumatisme des personnes ont été
hospitalisées en réanimation et elle ne
se remettent pas de cet épisode là
vraiment d'un point de vue psychologique
des personnes qui ne se retrouvent plus
comme elle était avant
une trentaine de personnes ont d'ores et
déjà pu bénéficier de ce dispositif mis
en place gratuitement un programme que
la municipalité annonce prolonger aussi
longtemps que nécessaire